hello everyone welcome back to PGA and
design channel today we would like to
talk about this cross pendant there are
many different way to make it but
especially I would like to talk about
how to get the surface nice smooth and
puffy I will show you a couple other
ways and talk about the pros and cons on
making those pendant are you ready let's
get started because I'm going to use
today is about three by four there are
many different type of lacrosse
especially if it's really religion
specific you may want to find online for
the specific propulsion but what I like
to do here is about three by four and we
use the rectangular tool to create you
rectangular and all we need to like
rectangle and all we need to do is trim
the curve in between and that's move
this one back to the center
so that's used a move tool and move it
back to the zero point alright so the
first way to make it really simple you
can make it into a solid by just pick up
the curve you have go into the solid and
then you can extrude a planar curve okay
so once you have it you can have any
thickness that you want it and all you
need to do is giving a little bit radius
so let's say we want to have a radius
one and you can have something like this
so that's the first one all right really
simple one but it look really stiff
alright and if we set a stone on it it
doesn't look good we want to have
something a little bit puffy so maybe
I'm thinking the way to make it puffy I
can have I can create an arc from let me
point here let's make sure that my
points on my point here my point here
and we want to go let's say for whatever
high that you like so let's say some
somewhere there
and another one we want to go here to
here and going up there alright so
something like this and then you can
adjust it if you wanted to say we wanted
to go this curve more puffy on that way
and this small let me hide this one it's
more tapered in this way so I'm gonna
move those two going here or something
like that you can create whatever you
like here but the only problem that I'm
seeing here is when I creating a surface
with those two curves so for example the
curve that I have I'm going to surface
extrude this straight and I want to make
sure both I equal yes and then we wanna
snapping into here the same thing we're
gonna do with this one snapping into a
day overall it doesn't look like much of
a problem we can close this really quick
but I'm going to enlarge the perspective
then you can see something like this the
age they doesn't call export respond
with the other one so that you have is a
gap here and there
alright so it doesn't do too good for
what we have but I just want to make it
and put it on this side as the that's
the comparison
so let me completely this cross what we
can do is I can make another curve here
another curve here and make sure I join
those two curve and join those two
curves
alright so again we are going to the
curve solid tool extruded planar curve
stray make sure both are equal yes and
this one we can have it this alright so
you can see if that's your design is
actually perfect you know you want to
have a little bit gap there so what we
need to do is following unit those two
then you have another type of the cross
and again this is not what I am looking
for I'm just put it there as a
comparison for you so we have cross one
and
we have crossed to here for the
comparison what I'd like to do is to
make something really nice and puffy
it's a continuous surface like a first
one but it has the pump on the top and
then it is a continuous surface so it's
not breaking here okay
all right so the way I'm going to do I
need to make a puffy surface first all
right so let's go to the top view let me
hide those two alright so what I like to
do on the top view I'm going to use the
the rectangle tool and then this is a
colony corner so right click on your
mouse this is the this the first corner
we're going to snapping into here the
second corner is here and we want to
make something a little bit rounded so
look nicer maybe turn off my grid snip
so somewhere about this okay so that's
first the second we need to find our
where's the center of the rectangular
you can see there's a point right there
but if you want to be exact we can go
ahead to use the analyze tool and
there's a mass property and you can find
the area central here so we click on
this curve and really quickly you see
that thought over there okay
so we're gonna move everybody to the
center it's just easier for me to model
if I can have the things aligned to the
zero point alright so I kind of
temporary to hide this one so it's not
part of us and I may need to have it a
little bit bigger look like this because
I'll cross need to be inside of the
shape because we need to cut it off
later all right so I'm gonna hide it the
cross first and put this into other
layer
and hide it alright so now what we need
to do is we need to decide how high do
we wanted to have so let's say I want to
have roughly about a millimeter there
okay I'm gonna put a little tag and my
from B we can see that as a little tag
here and another tag is somewhere here
right at a end point so for those two
I'm going to use the blend tool or here
and we want to blend from this one to
that one okay so you get this one right
there now once we got that we want to
use the command to create a surface it's
under the surface and it's called rail
revolve so what we do is we pick up this
as our profile this is a rail and we
want to go from here to here so that's
how we creating this surface okay now
with this surface what we need to do is
bring back our cross which is I just
hide it so that's show up the object and
let's take a look on the top view so now
we have this cross all we need to do is
use that cross to trim the extra off all
right so now you see is this is really
nice smooth surface right there
okay and you can create a thicknesses if
you want to or you can like like the
distance that I have here I can also
creating things in between and the very
easy way is you're actually going to
extruded that curve stray and we don't
need both sides we just need the one
going once
and then we want to make sure is higher
than that surface okay now we want to
use this surface to trim off the surface
right there so now we have a thickness
there all you need to do is make sure
that you join them and then you can use
the cap command to kappa since the
button is flat alright so this will be
the cross that we have us a basic after
that we can set the stone on the top of
it but we may also alter this a little
bit more sometimes for men's jewelry you
wanted doing some chamfer pages because
that make it look masculine so let's say
we want to set it a certain mention let
me put it one point five and we want to
choose all of them so now we can have a
completely different look of the cross
and once you have done you can go ahead
to do the stone setting on the top the
stone setting part us for the P setting
you can see my other video showing here
and I will put the link below the
description so you know how to do the
stone setting for the top and then you
can have something look like this I hope
you enjoy the video please like and
share and very important any comments on
my video let me know how you like it if
you have any suggestion of any other
things you would like to learn I will
try to make a video for you thank you
for watching see you next Monday